mais d'abord au lendemain de sa décision
de se confronter au vote des militants
ait l'air exavier bertrand était à la
manoeuvre ce matin au sénat jérôme
rabier à peine revenu dans le processus
de sélection des républicains xavier
bertrand doit désormais convaincre élus
et adhérents de se tourner vers lui avec
un leitmotiv où le rassemblement fait
cavalier seul en leurs proches je joue
le rassemblement où leurs proches ont
choisir ben moi j'ai choisi c'est le
rassemblement à d'où viendra la surprise
de cette élection présidentielle vous le
dire la surprise ou plutôt la logique
sera la victoire d'un candidat le rates
républicaine et du côté des élus qu'ils
soient soutien ou non du président de la
région haute france c'est le soulagement
ça veut dire que au 4 décembre nous
aurons un seul candidat un candidat
unique pour notre famille politique est
dès lors que cette condition de
rassemblement et réunit alors alors on
peut envisager figurer au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
1h30 devant le groupe l ère du sénat
présenté sa démarche et à répondre à
toutes les questions y compris celles
qui fâchent comme celle sur les raisons
de son départ des républicains il y a
quatre ans j'ai quitté mon parti à
l'époque je m'en suis expliqué très
clairement j'ai pas quitter ma famille
politique j'ai jamais rejoint notre
parti je n'ai jamais créé d'autres
partis et moi j'ai pas trahi non plus et
ça c'est aussi quelque chose de très
important
le pari de xavier bertrand redonne aussi
une saveur particulière au congrès où il
y aura un véritable enjeu avec tous les
acteurs nos militants se disaient non
mais ça sert à quoi qu'on aille au
congrès pourquoi est-ce qu'on va voter
parce que de toute façon le 4 décembre
se posera la question de sa vie bertrand
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il en restera une
ou un le 4 décembre en opération
séduction le candidat a toutefois dit
que non il ne reprendrait pas sa carte
au parti une manière de garder sa
liberté même s'il a été contraint de
s'inscrire dans le processus de sa
famille politique d'origine
xavier bertrand dans le piège du congrès
lr on en débat tout de suite je vous
présente mes invités martial foucault
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur à sciences po directeur du
cevipof le centre de recherches
politiques de sciences po sales rats
bilou sézanne bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes journée ce politique vous suivez la
droite pour le quotidien le monde
stewart show bonsoir soit venue de
consultants stratégies d'opinion chez
viavoice et lætitia copa bonsoir
laetitia c'est victoria liste de sens
public tous les mardis et tous les
jeudis on vient de le voir dans le
reportage xavier bertrand à la manoeuvre
au sénat comme aux cétacés on peut on
peut l'interpréter de deux façons c'est
logique c'est normal il est dans son
dans son habit de voilà de candidat en
campagne et puis on tire on peut aussi
se dire que il faut qu'il se retrouve
c'est manche parce que il n'est pas
gagné d'avancé ce scrutin dont je crois
que le titre de votre de votre reportage
est très bon c'est est-ce que vous avez
berton va être pris à son propre piège
mais j'ai quand même assez deux pièges
le premier piège c'est ce qui est
rappelé c'est sa décision de quitter la
famille et l'air en 2000 en 2010 est
fort de son aventure à la fois régionale
et c'est vrai qu'il a gagné du capital
politique par premier succès à la région
en 2015 et puis plus récemment l'an
printemps dernier
mais la droite reste la droite d'une
certaine manière c'est à dire que la
loyauté partisane ça compte pour cette
famille politique depuis très longtemps
donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'il peut
être pris au piège des adhérents dans
cette procédure de congrès qui pourrait
lui reprocher cet abandon en 2017 et il
n'a pas envoyé de signe de rapprochement
au gré des différentes échéances et des
difficultés qu'a rencontrées s'affaire
une politique et puis le deuxième piège
c'est celui de la procédure elle même
c'est à dire que dans un premier temps
et dit je ne veux pas participer nous
les maires à une primaire ouverte
primaires ouvertes et on peut comprendre
il ya de bonnes raisons
voyant que finalement cette procédure
est en train de se transformer un peu en
cacophonie au sein de sa famille
politique
ils se disent je vais quand même me
ranger à la procédure que
le comité de direction a choisi parce
que sinon je vais faire qu'à payer les
seuls diviseur je vais être peut-être
opposé un autre candidat de droite est
finalement aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est pris à un piège je sais pas si ce
piège il est totalement ouverts ou
fermés mais il est pris à un piège qui
est de devoir se confronter aux seuls
adhérents et l'air est là quand même ça
peut être la grande surprise la douche
froide alors on y reviendra sur les
possibilités effectivement à michel
barnier ou une valérie pécresse
l'emportent sa belouizad est ce que
c'est un choix par défaut et ce qui est
bien et ce qui est des tractations vous
qui suivez la droite qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans ces derniers jours avant le
finalement la décision de xavier
bertrand alors évidemment qu'il ya des
tractations en fait tout le monde a
essayé de le convaincre d'aller dans un
sens ou dans l'autre tous au sein du
parti il avait plutôt intérêt à ce que
finalement il y aille parce que ça
donnait de la crédibilité à un processus
qui sans lui n'auraient eu aucun sens
fait on allait se retrouver avec le
candidat favori des sondages en dehors
du processus et ensuite une espèce de
deux processus internes qui allait
donner lieu à une primaire sauvage par
la suite face allait être pas possible
et donc il y avait ça d'un côté et puis
de l'autre il ya ses proches à lui qui
eux étaient très divisés ces derniers
jours en fait quand on les appelait
c'était très intéressant en discuter
avec eux ils savaient pas quoi faire il
ya ceux qui lui disaient n'y va pas
c'est un piège les militants ne voteront
jamais pour toi et ceux qui lui disaient
il faut impérativement que tu viennes
parce que sinon tu seras le diviseur
celui qui est resté en dehors de sa
famille politique donc jusqu'à la
dernière minute personne ne savait en
fait vraiment jusqu'à la dernière minute
quand on discutait avec les membres de l
arrière enfin c'était une espèce de
suspense déjà même sur l'interview tf1
est ce qu'il ya une interview ce qui a
pas une interview finalement on a
confirmation dans l'après midi c'était
très court et 4000 tricoire 4030
absolument qu'on se court dans le
journal attendu par toute la droite
comme ça finalement donc à la dernière
minute il se décide et il y va et il ya
énormément de ses soutiens qui ont
découvert ça en fait en même temps que
nous tous
à la télévision alors je rappelle le
calendrier de désignation donc le 13
octobre c'est la date limite pour le
dépôt des candidatures ça explique aussi
sa l'annnonce de cette décision de
novembre dépôt il faut des parrainages
250 parrainage et la nausée résultat
c'est le 4 décembre au cours du congrès
si howard shore est ce qu on sait qui va
voter parce que ça c'est intéressant est
ce qu'on connaît un peu la morphologie
politique de des 80 mille militants lr
aujourd'hui
alors je vais répondre avec beaucoup
d'humilité non et bien sondeurs voit la
maison mais je préfère je préfère dire
non non très honnêtement je ne
m'aventurerai pas pour pour
proposer une éventuelle victoire de dao
d'une candidate par contre ce qui me
semble intéressant si si on en croit un
petit peu effectivement les dernières
intentions de vote alors il faut les
prendre évidemment avec beaucoup de
précautions sont des tendances à
observer c'est que effectivement xavier
bertrand si on regarde sur le rapport de
force politique
il a essayé finalement de jouer un petit
peu
à parier sur cette idée qui serait le
candidat qui représenterait assez
naturellement l'alternance et
l'opposition facile de la manuelle macro
c'est un candidat qui sait quand même
proclamé candidat en mars dernier dont
il ya quand même un essoufflement dans
le débat politique et médiatique avec
l'arrivée dans le débat politique de
personnages dont on n'ignore pas qui
fait qu'effectivement cette candidature
bertrand lors tout cas cette raison des
deux lacs entière durant bertrand mais
ces peines ne sait pas forcément en tout
cas
réalisé dans l'opinion notamment chez
sympathisants de droite donc quand on
regarde la dynamique bertrand c'est que
finalement il y en a très peu ils
profitent surtout d'une dégringolade
marine le pen ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
il arriverait selon certaines intentions
au coude à coude mais la dynamique
réelle qui pourrait finalement lui faire
endosser le candidat un petit peu
naturel de la droite dans une dans un
parti qui a quand même le culte du chef
et du candidat naturel bah ça ne s'est
pas forcément réaliser donc je pense
qu'effectivement il a été je dirais
contraint peut-être par la conjoncture
en tout cas de participer à ce congrès
mais messi gagne
imaginons qu'il gagne il ya 80 on l'a vu
le chiffre il ya 80 mille inscrits
aujourd'hui le on peut pas en dire c'est
un petit est lancée - qu'europe écologie
les verts si on compare à ce qui s'était
passé lors des primaires ya cinq ans
c'était 4 millions de participants bref
on a connu on a connu plus puissant
qu'en mêlant de départ oui non mais
peut-être que le parti ait l'air qui a
découvert les vertus récemment des des
enquêtes d'opinion pour savoir quelles
procédures choisir wii aura peut-être
envie avant le 4 décembre d'utiliser ce
fichier des adhérents pourront connaître
un petit peu plus sur leurs abords des
forces des candidats blague à part la
sociologie de cet électorat est très
difficile à positionner pour chacune des
candidatures vraiment c'est s'est réduit
si donc on a par an on n'a pas de boule
de cristal mais je pense qu'on a quand
même deux éléments importants dans le
ressenti des adhérents et l'eire qui
sont quand même encore sous le
traumatisme de 2016 2017 assure et que
finalement ce qu'ils n'ont pas quitté le
navire après ce choc ont peut-être un
petit avantage je dis bien un petit
avantage et donc il faut bien voir que
d'ailleurs sur 80 mille adhérents je
suis pas certain qu'il ya 80 mille
votants 1 le 4 décembre ils seront pas
tous mobilisables et mobilisés et on
peut se dire que effectivement la
candidature de valérie pécresse et
xavier bertrand va souffrir de cette
absence de loyauté alors est-ce que les
preuves d'amour ni l'un ni l'autre non
leur carte du parti
d'une pin et puis pas pouvoir voter pour
eux pardon mais ça fait c'est quand même
le souligner oui je crois qu'ils sont
quand même aujourd'hui non seulement le
calendrier qu'a décembre c'est très tard
se rendent bien compte qu'aujourd'hui un
automne où on va parler de l ère d'une
machinerie d'une tuyauterie ou on ne
sait pas quelle est la procédure quel
est le candidat il n'y a pas de candidat
naturel faut trouver une procédure cette
procédure ne semble pas légitime pour
tout le monde et donc pendant ce temps
là il se passe des choses pendant la
campagne donc peut-être que le vote des
adhérents au delà d'un caractère de
sympathie pour tel et tel candidat y
aurait une question de crédibilité
la crédibilité il s'agira de rattraper
le retard pris pendant trois mois quatre
mois pour essayer de donner un blanc
seing à un candidat ou une candidate qui
deviendra crédible pour essayer de
franchir le premier tour j'ai bien
essayé de franchir le bon bien sûr que
vous faisiez référence à cette enquête
ifop qui a été commandé par les
républicains effectivement pour voilà
définir leur processus de éclairé
désignation éclairé c'est ça c'est le
terme que je cherchais merci beaucoup ça
il ya notamment cette question quel est
le meilleur candidat pour battre
emmanuel macron est ce que xavier
bertrand est le meilleur pour battre
emmanuel macron donc c'est auprès des
électeurs de droite c'est c'est assez
vaste
71% pour xavier bertrand 56% pour le
valérie pécresse 38% michel barnier avec
ce tee philippe bas son sont derrière ce
qui est sûr laetitia c'est que là dans
la stratégie de de xavier bertrand il ya
là confié cherchent la confrontation
avec le prix de la république ça ce oui
je pense que monsieur vous avez
effectivement adressé un bon constat
c'est à dire que là on va avoir ce qui
nous sépare quelques semaines du 4
décembre et tout va se jouer dans ce
moment là ça va se cristalliser et
xavier bertrand c'est qu'il peut déjà
capitalisé sur les confrontations qu'il
a eue en direct avec le chef de l'état
c'est à dire ce face à face aux hommes
où il a montré aussi qu'il pouvait tenir
tête à emmanuel macron il y en a eu
trois finalement parce que c'est le chef
de l'état qui va sur les terres oui
c'est à l'occasion
donc c'est le chef de l'état qui voyant
un potentiel rival dans xavier bertrand
s'est dit ça c'est la technique des
manuels macron je vais le baiser de
l'araignée on étouffe l'ennemi donc il a
fait trois déplacements et à chaque fois
c'était quand même un peu tendu un le
premier c'était le 17 mai à montcornet
pour l'hommage au général de gaulle et
la xavier bertrand se fait remarquer
parce qu'il refuse de retirer son masque
alors que la cérémonie est à l'extérieur
ensuite il est doué fin juin emmanuel
macron le féliciter vient d'être élue
réélu xavier bertrand et là il lui
glisse xavier bertrand à emmanuel macron
qu'il y ait une colère sociale
sous-entendu que le chef de l'état n'a
pas su écouter et n'a pas éteint et
ensuite il y a ce dernier déplacement
c'était il ya le 14 septembre dernier
emmanuel macron choisi roubaix pour
aller annoncer les conclusions du bureau
de la sécurité or le lendemain xavier
bertrand avait prévu de lui même de
faire un discours sur la sécurité donc
on sent qu'il ya une tension entre les
deux hommes et je vous propose de
regarder cet échange qui est court mais
intense
ce républicain
[Musique]
de continuer
après avoir
perdu le match ce jour-là xavier
bertrand beaucoup ont dit qu'ils avaient
perdu le match il me semble que non
parce que encore une fois vous avez
raison monsieur les images sont très
importantes peut-être plus que les mots
on n'a jamais su vraiment quantifier
l'impact de des images ou des mots mais
cette image d'un xavier bertrand tenant
tête à emmanuel macron lecerf je pense
qu'il va capitaliser et il va peut-être
lui même cette fois-ci provoqué ce type
de rencontre parce que pour l'instant
ses concurrents ses concurrents au sein
de l'air n'ont pas ce capital image donc
il faut voir un dans les prochaines
semaines je n'ai pas d'information mais
c'est une hypothèse qui effectivement il
va essayer de répéter cette séquence si
on est là dans dans ce débat sur le
match en tout cas que xavier bertrand on
doit bien d'installer entre lui et le
chef de l'état à stewart show c'est quoi
le socle électoral de xavier bertrand
est ce qui est ce qu'il ya pas mal de
finalement de porosité entre l'électorat
xavier bertrand et celui du du chef de
l'état toujours si non cross et ses
différentes intentions de vote et si on
regarde en granularité des profils
effectivement il ya une à une
un parallèle entre l'électorat emmanuel
macron électorat et xavier bertrand qui
peut se faire de manière assez assez
clairement c'est à dire qu'on a des
électorats plutôt de csp + est plutôt de
plutôt âgées retraitées plus de 65 ans
d'ailleurs sur les plus de 65 ans alors
que c'est un électorat qui est
traditionnellement votre beaucoup plus à
droite ils font jeu égal aujourd'hui
dans les rapports de force politiques
donc c'est vrai que à la fois sur la
base de l'idéologie parce que sinon
c'est dans cet état dès son âge
d'opinion et des scores on le voit que
d'ailleurs vous avez raison de le
rappeler sur des termes qui sont propres
à la droite la sécurité mais aussi
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron annonce son
grand plan pour la france 2030 parle de
réindustrialisation de la france ils
allaient bertrand sa première
proposition c'est ça notamment dans les
territoires dont il est aussi une
conflictuelle it et à retrouver entre
les deux mais encore une fois cette
raison d'être xavier bertrand face à
présent la république elle est encore
difficile à cerner pour les électeurs de
droite mais alors effectivement le
territoire avec l'autorité le travail
c'est les trois axes on va dire de la
campagne de xavier bertrand il les a
rappelé ce matin devant les sénateurs et
l'air on écoute j'ai expliqué trois
grands chantiers qui sont les miens dans
le cas de mon projet pour la france et
pour les français le rétablissement de
l'autorité et quand vous voyez ce qui
s'est passé à combs-la-ville avec cet
enseignant de vendredi dernier qui a été
agressée à peut pas durer pour
rétablissement de l'autorité société du
travail quand vous entendez aujourd'hui
tous ces français qui travaillent qui
n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir pour qui la
fin du mois c'est le 5 ou le dit ça peut
pas continuer non plus je propose des
solutions et puis avec les sénateurs qui
sont aussi les représentants des
territoires dans cette assemblée la
république des territoires avait une
résonance particulière
sarah b louisiane est ce que est ce que
vous sentez une fébrilité
chez xavier bertrand et dans son
entourage depuis depuis quelques jours
stewart show parler d'une sorte
d'essoufflement après une entrée qu'en
essais six mois effectivement qu'il est
en campagne alors évidemment vous disent
pas du tout une lettré sort ans le
discours le discours classique mais en
fait on évidemment fait évidemment sinon
il ne serait peut-être pas aller comme
ça il serait je serais pas revenu dans
le processus interne parce qu'après tout
la la il va faire tout ce qui ne voulait
pas faire parce que il est ok maintenant
pour faire des débats pour apparaître en
fait au même niveau que les autres
langues depuis le début il s'attache à
être on en parlait tout à l'heure à être
celui qui peut faire la confrontation
aucun manuel macro et qui donc est
différent c'est à dire qu'il est au
dessus de la mêlée lundi la e-lettre un
niveau des autres sauf que cet argument
et devient un peu obsolète alors parlons
parlons de revenir encore aux sondages
et aux enquêtes d'opinion mais là c'est
vrai que là il est au mieux 3e au pire
quatrième rôle dans les incidents alors
est ce qui selon les enquêtes oui tout à
fait absolument sauf que lui ont dit oui
oui sauf que le oui absolument enfin il
est pas encore au second temps alors lui
il dit je suis le seul à pouvoir être au
second tour mais c'est vrai que les
sondages sont parfois le donnent parfois
trois points nous vend parfois quatre
points devant parfois juste un point
devant valérie pécresse alors michel
barnier est encore est encore derrière
mais il estime quand même que ça fait
six mois que ça dure six mois qu'il est
devant et qu'en fait c'est le seul à
pouvoir y arriver et que et que ce sera
finalement sa carte maîtresse alors
évidemment lui dit qu'il va parler de de
ses propositions et ses mais que quand
il ira voir les militants parce que là
il a quand même du travail un là il faut
aller les chercher les militants ont
parlé de leur profil tout à l'heure qui
est difficile à établir c'est quand même
on sait quand même que c'est les murs et
les personnes qui sont restées alors que
le parti était en pleine déliquescence
et c'est qu'il faut qu'il aille les
chercher il faut qu'ils aillent leur
dire je ne suis pas je ne vous ai pas
trahir
je suis je fais partie de la famille
politique et je suis le seul si vous
voulez jouer la gagne si vous voulez
même jouer la survie je suis le seul à
pouvoir vous menez au second tour de la
présidentielle ça va être tout
l'argumentaire
finalement en fait et xavier bertrand
c'est le premier fan des manuels macron
parce qu'en 2017 quand il a vu ma qu'on
gagne et il a choisi sa stratégie c'est
à dire au lendemain de la victoire
d'emmanuel mâcon lui il s'est dit avec
ses troupes évidemment ses intimes moi
j'irai aussi comme ça sans parti et dans
cette rencontre fantasmer entre le
peuple français et un homme et comme
emmanuel macron qui avait évité un le
débat de la primaire à gauche il a fait
il a voulu suivre le même chemin or en
politique je sais pas mais souvent
surtout quand c'est comme ça comme un
peu un casse le casse du siècle emmanuel
macron qui arrive à l'elysée c'est rare
que ça se répète mais donc je pense
qu'il faut un tout petit peut être avoir
des idées neuves et puis un chemin neuf
et puis une nouvelle stratégie or il a
il a vraiment il était convaincu qu'il y
arriverait comme ça et quand il se
retourne aujourd'hui
dans la mécanique du parti pardon d'être
trivial martial foucault il ya aussi un
argument dont on n'a pas encore parlé
c'est l'argent il revient aussi dans le
processus ait l'air parce que voilà il
ya l'argent d'un parti politique
structuré et puissant même si les plus
faibles qu'avant oui et si on fait un
petit peu l'inventaire des deux
dernières élections présidentielles
l'argent et les campagnes électorales
mots et l'air ne font pas toujours bon
ménage avec des tissus parfois compliqué
mais donc moi je vous avez raison de
dire que effectivement pour xavier
bertrand il va y avoir un enjeu faisons
un peu de fiction parce que là on est on
est dans une purée de pois sinon si le
cas décembre c'est xavier bertrand qui
l'emportent et vous avez raison de dire
que c'est provence lui qui est dans ce
rapport e j'allais dire presque
conflictuelle d'opposition permanente et
je rajouterais même un quatrième rendez
vous sur les terres de xavier bertrand
c'est lorsque le gouvernement a envoyé
sept de ses membres pour les élections
régionales mais chacun est revenu un
petit peu bredouille mettons de côté
gérald darmanin pour les élections
départementales mais quand même c'est un
point important qui compte aussi de la
stratégie pour mourir en tête d'affiché
et donc je dirais que pour xavier
bertrand s'il sort vainqueur du congrès
il va devoir effectivement évité
j'allais dire le produit et navy table
des congrès et des
processus de primaires qui est un moment
donné on se divise entre soi pour
afficher une singularité et dès le
lendemain quelques heures après il
faudrait que tout le monde se soit en
mesure de se rabibocher et être main
dans la main dans une campagne ça c'est
pas simple c'est vraiment pas simple et
je pense que l' aventure de xavier
bertrand depuis quatre ans ne va pas
l'aider ensuite la question
effectivement la logistique que le
financement l'organisation d'une dune
d'une élection présidentielle demande
l'appui d'un parti politique alors le
contre exemple des modèles macron quand
même oui mais il avait il avait eu cette
capacité de levée de fonds importante et
au fond aujourd'hui les républicains
alors je ne sais pas où ils en sont
exactement en termes est ce qu'ils ont
réussi à apurer la dette qui avait été
accumulé depuis de longues années mais
bon pour cette campagne on sait qu'en
général un candidat pour une élection
aux présidentielles jaillir pour un
parti comme heller c'est autour de 15 à
18 millions d'euros pour une campagne
présidentielle donc il faudra qu'il
trouve cet argent en général la moitié
du parti ont fait la france parce
qu'elle est remboursé par par l'état
mais je rajouterais un point si vous
nous permettez en fait on va avoir trois
candidats qui ont chacun des figures
contrastée xavier bertrand et hors
partis mais c'est celui qui est dans
l'opposition directe vis-à-vis des
mailheuls macron c'est vrai que c'est
pas le cas de michel barnier c'est pas
le cas de valérie pécresse est
d'ailleurs valérie pécresse on dit
finalement les adhérentes dit je crois
très souvent elle est un peu trop macron
compatibles donc ce qui peut provoquer
une forme de gênes et est là
l'inconvénient
de cette macro compatibilité mail
avantage l'avantagent important qui est
celle qui a donné quand même d'aider des
signes d'attachement à sa famille
politique je crois beaucoup plus fort
que xavier bertrand et enfin michel
barnier qui est en dehors en dehors du
jeu politique national donc il peut à il
a un capital politique très très fort et
plusieurs fois ministre plusieurs
services mais il ya très longtemps elle
entend il ya très longtemps et je trouve
que mais c'est peut-être ça c'est un
avantage qui c'est un inconvénient qui
devient un avantage presque un homme
neuf exactement et qui est fidèle à
cette tradition finalement du rpr ces
voix là c'est même pas de l'ump de
répéter c'est une tradition est ce que
est ce que le fait que valérie pécresse
soit une femme est un atout pour les
militants aient l'air comment poser la
question
très difficile de répondre à cette
question très difficile parce que c'est
vrai on ne sait pas exactement à quoi
ressemblait militants mais on sait une
chose ce sont ceux qui sont restés et
donc on suppose d'après ce que disent
aussi les présidents de fédérations qui
les connaît à saint qui vont les voir
régulièrement c'est ce sont des
militants qui sont calmes plus à droite
que lors que leurs élus de la question
avec une petite pointe d'ironie mais
parce que en fait ils ont un pur et les
contres bien sûr ils ont un pur les
comptes daniel fasquelle hacker le
trésorier a mis de l'argent de côté
entre 8 et 10 millions d'euros si je me
souviens bien en fait il y là il a
nettoyé les comptes et là il est prêt en
fait daniel fasquelle est prêt pour la
campagne sa peau mais lui il soutient
michel barnier donc la blague sheller
c'est daniel fasquelle va pas donner le
magot à xavier bertrand a envoyé ses
s'est en fait toujours cette blague à
droite montre capable selon bertrand il
a besoin il a besoin d'aidé pas que de
l'argent et la maison des militants qui
vont tracter il a besoin des élus locaux
qui vont le recevoir quand il fera un
déplacement
des militants qui sont présents alors
des réunions publiques où il doit faire
montre de sa démonstration un petit peu
de force on va revenir sur sûr
évidemment l'hypothèse michel barnier
mais j'aurais quand même con ou une
petite parenthèse dans ce débat sur le
poids des sondages là pour pour 7,7 ce
processus de désignation et lherm et
même plus généralement dans cette
campagne dans cette pré campagne stewart
show faudrait peut-être que nous
journalistes et là j'en prends ma part
on a fait ensemble pendant des années
une émission sur le travail des médias
et voilà et comment les blés
journalistes et les médias traiter
l'actualité mais on sait pas assez
pédagogie sur les sondages alors que
quand on donne les résultats d'un d'une
enquête d'opinion aujourd'hui la 12
octobre
ça paraît à nos téléspectateurs on a des
airs comme une prédiction moi je
reprends ma part soyons honnête il n'y a
pas assez de pédagogie
alors de deux éléments dre de réponse le
premier élément sur le contexte dans
lequel aussi s'inscrit cette
interprétation des sondages et la
frénésie qui a autour de céder ses
intentions de vote alors jean plus je
suis totalement à l'aise pour en parler
puisque viavoice pour l'instant dans
produits absolument aucune en tout cas
de publier sur les intentions de vote ce
contexte politique il est quand même
assez particulier
a'salfo pourra très bien le décrire mais
il ya effectivement une métamorphose
aujourd'hui des partis politiques qui ne
sont plus des instances qui sélectionne
les candidats de matières naturelles
d'ailleurs on peut aussi débattre de la
force des partis politiques à être force
de proposition d'idées puisque oeil là
aujourd'hui les compétences et
l'influencent de certaines fondations
associations etc parfois on a même
l'impression que le débat d'idées se
fait à l'extérieur des partis il ya
effectivement aussi cette question de
l'information du rapport aux
journalistes il faut commenter tout le
temps la vie politique et donc il faut
des supports aussi pour commenter cette
vie politique ce qui amplifie parfois
cet appel à des supports tels que les
études d'opinion et puis la troisième
chance il ya une incertitude politique
aujourd'hui qui est tel que on a
toujours envie en tout cas de savoir et
de prendre le pouls de mesurer l'opinion
joie plusieurs écueils vous avez raison
la question de la pédagogie a été
essentielle elle incombe aux
journalistes à la combustion aux
instituts de 10 effectivement les
limites les biais de certains outils les
marges d'erreur m'ont jamais rappelé
absolument alors il ya des notes
techniques mais on peut aller au delà de
ces deux là on peut aller au delà de ça
pour dire aussi nous sont là sur les
chiffres sur lesquels on est à l'aise ou
pas on peut dire aussi sur certains
chiffres que il suffit pas d'interpréter
un chiffre l'étude d'opinion c'est la
capacité de mettre en mots un chiffre
mais aussi en cohérence avec d'autres
chiffres je pense que ça c'est aussi
important d'avoir cette cette volonté de
rentrer dans la adroit dans la
complexité de ce que peut être une
opinion et puis ensuite le levier le
troisième écueil c'est c'est penser que
l'opinion a toujours raison je pense que
l'opinion est de plus en plus elle est
régie par l'ordre aussi des émotions et
qu'il ya une forme de versatilité de
l'opinion l'apparition de
cristallisation on n'y est pas encore
absolument absolument o'keefe et qui
fait que bon sur une étude sur des
études d'opinion qui sont parfois
réalisé extrêmement tôt et ça c'est vrai
et ça c'est une question éthique de se
poser la question est ce que oui ou non
on fait une intention de vote en 2017
pour 2022 ça c'est des questions qu'on
peut qu'on peut se poser donc sur ce
registre là je pense qu'il faut il faut
il faut prendre à notre charge ces
écueils linge pense qu'il faut les
présenter il faut être complètement
transparent sur ça mais après faut pas
non plus confondre l'outil et
l'interprétation que l'on aboutit alors
ça vous faire réagir les uns et les
autres avant de vous donner la parole et
fait signe tous les de laetitia et
marcel foucault jaurès à quelle est la
politique du monde alors de son dos
alors nous on ne commentera les sondages
des autres c'est à dire que dans les
papiers on les cite éviter évidemment là
le fameux harris turquie mais zemmour à
17 fonctionnement le site parce qu'il a
un impact sur ce que pensent les
politiques est ce qu'ils font après on
ne va jamais faire un papier entièrement
tourné autour d'un sondage que nous
n'avons pas commander
nous on a on aura en outre nos vagues de
sondages à nous
sur un échantillon je sais plus de dix
mille personnes je crois voilà quinze
mille
donc on fond comment vont aller jusque
oui c'est plus que les parfois c'est
parfois six ans que parfois ça tourne
autour de 6 ans parfois mille et sinon
on considère qu' on ne les cite que
quand ils ont un impact comment dire sur
sur ce que font les politiques whisky
alors la question et complémentaires
parce que je ne sais pas si tous les
téléspectateurs le 5 mai par exemple
parce que vous parlez de sondages
publiés ou non le sondage qui paraît
dans un journal ou à une télé ou dans
une radio c'est bien le média qui vous
l'a commandé bah ça dépend ça peut être
un média où ça peut être un
commanditaire qui n'est pas le média qui
est peut être un acteur privé avec un
partenariat média avec un partenaire
média qui c'est qui c'est je dirais
proclamé pour la diffusion d'une pour la
publication du sondage mais ben c'est
pas toujours en tout cas le média qui
finança peut l'être mais ce n'est pas
toujours le cas c'est à dire qu'il ya un
parti politique et voilà c'est pour ça
je pose la question ça peut arriver
alors moi je n'ai pas le mais ça peut
arriver absolument pas ce qu'il faut
savoir qui commande parce que nous on
est tous toujours à la remorque de des
résultats de tous non mais du d'un
déplacement une phrase d'une prise de
position d'un sondage très bien il faut
peut être regarder ce comment ça se
passe en amont comment ça se fabrique
qui commandent pourquoi plutôt que de se
dire 17 15 14 12 et donc si avec ça on
sait c'est déjà arrivé à chaque campagne
électorale le journal est toujours un
journal tizi ouzou m intel en deuxième
position qualifiée pour le second tour
et c'est là c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec eric zemmour ou les prendre la
parole moi je suis certain que public
sénat par exemple est une est une chaîne
suffisamment sérieuse pour ne plus
jamais publié en termes d'infographie à
l'écran un sondage commandé avec un
chiffre magique qui donne cette illusion
de scientificité et là on voit un
chiffre 17 23 10 et la vérité a fait la
tendance des eaux ça n'arrivera plus
après cette émission
j'ai déjà fait avant et je continuerai
de le faire mais où on prend des
précautions maj oratoire je pense que
c'est ce qui moi je jeu depuis plusieurs
années je donne un cours à l'école de
journalisme à sciences po sur les
sondages la fabrique des sondages et
alors on est dans une année particulière
jeu j'ai expliqué mes étudiants quelque
chose qui est important et la pédagogie
il s'agit pas de dire les journalistes
ne sont pas prêts à appréhender cette
matière qui parfois est compliqué c'est
à la fois bien sûr pour le traitement
éditorial mais c'est aussi avoir des
éléments de confrontation avec les
instituts à chivu commandé le sondage
pour dire écoutez le travail que vous
avez fait ne correspond pas à ce que je
sais de la manière dont on fabrique un
sondage donc je ne prendrai pas ce
sondage et je ne les dit rien et ça ne
paye pas et je ne paye pas je pense
qu'il faut abandonner aussi faire preuve
de responsabilité politique par rapport
au fait que c'est un matériel qui joue
sur le fonctionnement de nos démocraties
et donc je voyais on parlait beaucoup et
ça m'ennuie de parler de ce sondage
publié par
le magazine challenges qui déclencha
mais moi quand on regarde attentivement
on est incapable vraiment incapable si
on se donne le temps de regarder
attentivement les choses de savoir qui
est 2e 3e 4e 5e quand vous parlez des
marges d'erreur c'est pour ça une
suggestion ne présenter que les
intervalles et vous allez voir que tout
se chevaucher c'est à dire au fond c'est
un ballet régresse entre eux
14h30 retrait et qui est donc vous
comprenez qu'une fois qu' on ne peut
plus dire qui est 2e 3e 4e 5e ça fait
pas vendre des journaux plus tard et
puis on passe un peu son chemin pour
regarder peut-être une autre actualité à
notre angle de cette campagne vous et
moi je pourtant je suis je ne suis pas
un soutien b à des instituts et des
sondages puisque on fabrique des
questionnaires au cevipof on mène ces
dispositifs notamment avec le monde en
effet où près de 25000 personnes pendant
deux ans entre 2015 et 2017 parce qu'on
était intéressé pour suivre la dynamique
électorale mais quand on a cette
frénésie cette ivresse comme aurait pu
titrer un un sociologue sur les sondages
c'est vrai que on a une responsabilité
vous nous dans l' usage que l'on doit en
faire et la pédagogie ça passe pas
chaque journaliste devrait savoir ce qui
est éditorial élise dernier mot là
dessus ça en fait le problème auquel on
est tous confrontés aussi c'est que ça
c'est une prophétie auto réalisatrice
qui a aussi son impact sur le
comportement des politiques eux mêmes
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui en fait la
droite de choisy en fait son candidat ou
sa aimerait que son candidat soit
choisie comme ça c'est dire qu'un a
plein qui disent il faut que ce soit
bertrand parce que c'est berton qui est
devant dans les sondages il faut que les
militants le sache est-ce qu'il ya aussi
ceux qui disent il faut zemmour soit
intégrée aux bleuets parce que alors ça
c'est la question taboue personne ne
répond c'est la question très compliqué
très compliqué parce que au sein de
l'ers ils sont ils sont dans un ils sont
sur une ligne de crête en fait il y en a
qui estime que zemmour n'a rien avoir à
faire avec eux après tout il est
d'extrême droite après tout il tient des
propos révisionnistes
donc les jamais de la vie et puis
d'autres qui en fait peut être un peu
par opportunisme estiment que leur
électorat est sensible à ce qu'il dit et
n'osent pas en fait dire de lui ce qu'il
pense réellement ou ce qu'il ce qu'ils
disent
en finale et après évidemment il ya ceux
qui sont aussi d'accord avec lui à bien
des égards gérard larcher sur ce thème
c'était ce matin sur france info eric
zemmour n'a rien à faire au congrès elle
est en écoute il n'est pas le bienvenu
il n'était pas le bienvenu eric zemmour
il soulève des vraies questions que se
posent les français que ce soit la
question migratoire la question de
l'europe la question de la sécurité mais
dans tous ces propos ils fracturent
alors qu'il nous faut rassembler et
quelque part redonner confiance aux
français et puis le sujet c'est joliment
dit et redit sur lequel je me sens
nullement concordance de phase avec eric
zemmour sa position sur les femmes sa
position sur l'histoire de notre pays à
un moment particulièrement dramatique de
l'état français sa position sur la
laïcité
enfin je suis tout sauf zemmour
vous voyez la prudence quand même la
présence des propos c'est à dire qu'il
n'y va jamais franco il dit pas ni pas
ce type n'a rien avoir à faire avec nous
encore une fois il est d'extrême droite
il ne le dit il le dit pas il dit il
soulève des questions qui intéressent
les français mais je ne suis pas
d'accord et en fait au sein de l air il
se disant même il n'a rien à faire au
congrès c'est vrai alors lui le dit lui
le dit
d'autres légumes dans dix ans vous avez
tout à fait raison je suis tout sauf des
mots si on écoute tout ce qu'il a dit
dans la minuit en tournée à perseigne
c'est pas du tout ce qu'il dit donc il
faut commencer par cette conclusion et
dire ensuite expliqué pourquoi il est
tous aux mêmes sachant que larcher comme
celui qui a déplu
les plus claires sur ces - xavier
bertand aussi il a été assez clair
l'enseignant jacob aussi plus alors
jacob sur rtl je sais plus quand il ya
deux ou trois serres dont le pose la
question à ce que zemmour est
infréquentable
il répond non et on ne peut pas dire
qu'il est infréquentable alors oui jacob
dit que zemmour n'a rien à voir avec le
parti et n'a rien à faire au congrès
mais il ne dit pas qu'il est
infréquentable se dire que pour eux
c'est comme s'ils ne mettaient pas au
même niveau que marine le pen là où
certains le considèrent comme plus
radical encore comment ils opèrent allez
on va parler de michel barnier
maintenant pardon je vais je vais
reprendre l'enquète il faut qui a été
commandé par les républicains c'était ça
c'était quand même un événement qu'un
parti politique face à cette démarche
pour comparer la cote de popularité
alors d'abord parmi les électeurs de
droite xavier bertrand est donné à 53%
vallée j'ai pas les fourchettes valérie
pécresse 51 michel barnier je suis piégé
là c'est thomas hugues dans le piège de
michel barnier à 41% et sur la côte de
popularité parmi les sympathisants et
les airs on a je veux voir les chiffres
parce que je pense que sur ma sur ma
fille je suis en train de danser ça
valérie pécresse 80% xavier bertrand 79
c'était serré et michel barnier 67%
marcel foucault au delà de ces chiffres
qui sont très justes libres et besoin de
marge d'erreur c'est pas une intention
de vote donc c'est un seul et de la cote
de popularité c'est une cote voilà c'est
ainsi un score d'accord est-ce que avec
tout ce qu'on a dit auparavant michel
barnier a une vraie chance de remporter
ces primaires et l'air d'après vous je
répondrai qu'il a aujourd'hui
moins de chance de perdre qu'il ne
l'avait avant le choix du congrès dans
une primaire ouverte je pense que michel
g michel barnier avait peu de chances de
l'emporter là les choses ont changé à
l'électorat s'est rétréci inde électorat
dont on l'a dit dans la fidélité la
loyauté comptait beaucoup dans la
décision électorale et qui vint petit à
petit devenir finalement
c'est un peu une forme de des élections
je peux pas dire le candidat par défaut
ça serait très très méchant vis-à-vis de
de michel barnier ou tout autre candidat
mais voyez ce principe qui avait un peu
théorisé l'historien pierre rosanvallon
en disant on est rentré dans des moments
de des élections d'ailleurs on choisit
pas le candidat que l'on souhaite mais
le moins mauvais des candidats et je
pense que michel barnier compte tenu de
ce que l'on a évoqué tout à l'heure pour
xavier bertrand est au fond valérie
pécresse en dehors du jeu et qui ont eu
leur aventure personnelle peut remettre
michel barnier au centre de cette
élection et créer une surprise donc je
pense que il ne faut certainement pas
écartée il faut ce serait faux de penser
que c'est un duel pécresse bertrand
michel barnier est d'ailleurs dans cette
enquête ifop sur les traits de
personnalité on voit que il n'est pas
très loin il assure les des éléments les
traits d'image qu'on a l'habitude
d'utiliser est-ce qu'il a la capacité à
défendre les intérêts de la france
est-ce qu'il al'étoffe d'un président
est ce qu'il est capable de prendre des
mesures impopulaires même si elles sont
bonnes pour le pays où on voit que il
est pas très loin voire même parfois à
égalité avec ses deux autres adversaires
donc oui moi je pense que l'on peut
imaginer je sais pas si on doit parler
de surprise aujourd'hui tellement les
écarts sont faibles mais michel barnier
peut tout à fait profiter de cette
procédure congrès pour l'emporter mais
c'est un peu basique ce que je vais dire
mais
il ya aussi le physique
on
l'entend cazaban et s'est pas totalement
d'autres on dit de lui qu'il al'étoffe
en effet d'un président de la république
parce qu'en plus il connaît les chefs
d'état étrangers il les a fréquentés
après ça fait pas tous enfin il le
reconnaît il le reconnaît lui-même et
pour revenir ce que sur ce que disait
mon seul coup en fait le sait a priori
il se il peut même être le favori là
aujourd'hui on est dans une espèce de
situation d'après après évidemment
personne n'a fait sondages c'est c'est
vraiment du doigt mouillé ce pas ce que
ressentent les deux reporters ça oui
c'est ce que ressentent
ce dont on se rend compte en effet en
les voyant ce qu'on voit aussi la
rentrée des jeunes élèves en septembre
début septembre qui ont sifflé celui
dont vous avez bertrand est sifflée et
valérie pécresse elle a rameuté plein de
franciliens donc ça allait mais mais
marly a été a été acclamé donc en fait
on est dans une espèce de situation
ubuesque où selon les sondages pour
lesquels on n'a pas en effet
les têtes les vraies valeurs xavier
bertrand est favori en france dans tout
le pays est en fait mais les challengers
au sein de son propre parti où ça pour
être finalement barney le favori ce qui
ce qui suscite à la fois de
l'enthousiasmé chez les soutiens de
barney et ce qui inquiète énormément
chez tous les autres et oui les six
meilleurs jeux pour ajouter il peut
gagner les primaires pas forcément
devenir un
tout petit point sur les soutiens
parlementaires on voit que c'est très
serré et voire même à michèle bernier et
valérie pécresse ont un nom de soutien
parlementaire très important pour deux
soi-disant challenger d'un candidat
favori xavier bertrand donc et ça c'est
quand même très important parce que là
il va se produire six à dix semaines
durant lesquelles ça va travailler
usinés turbuler sérieusement dans les
fédérations pour aller convaincre les
adhérents d'aller voter stewart show
vous disiez tout à l'heure qui avait un
peu une forme d'essoufflement dans la
campagne de xavier bertrand qui a
démarré il ya six mois est ce que au
contraire dans celle de xavier berre de
michel barnier il ya dynamique est ce
que vous ressentez ça ou est-ce que vous
pouvez l'analyse et une dynamique encore
une fois ça c'est très difficile à
analyser le contenu du fait qu'on ne
dispose que de deux mesures à l'échelle
nationale c'est difficile de
l'apercevoir puisqu'il est quand même là
pour le coup relégué à la troisième
place derrière pécresse et et bertrand
pour autant je pense qu'il ya un élément
intéressant c'est sur les traits d'image
là où on peut vraiment sur la différence
sur un vote du congrès sur les traits
d'image de xavier bertrand effectivement
à la faveur d'un grand président de
région on lui prête la capacité
d'apporter des solutions utiles aux
français et l'idée proximité des
arguments d'ailleurs qui face à un
candidat peu hypothétique sortant
président de la république peut avoir un
effet un effet d'opposition et conflit
assez intéressant pour autant je pense
honoré électorat de droite ça ne peut
pas suffire et 7 ses traits d'image sont
parfois même sur déterminant sur cette
proximité cette utilité on attend
surtout en fait d'un candidat de droite
qui soient effectivement je dirais à
l'image d'un chef d'état avec une
carrure et avec cette volonté en cas de
représenter le pays et internationale là
c'est l'un des rares items ou michel
valet peut être au-dessus dé xavier
bertrand pour je voudrais terminer avec
le le rôle potentiel d'un laurent
wauquiez n'aime pas beaucoup xavier
bertrand ce même une litote ça va mais
lausanne est-ce que vous pouvez nous
rappeler pourquoi et xavier bertand le
lui rend bien oui oui j'imagine alors il
ya évidemment le fait qu'ils ne sont pas
sur la même ligne ça c'est la version
officielle ils sont bertrand et plus
sociale
alors vous qui est plus haut à droite
mais il ya aussi et à droite beaucoup
s'en souviennent et les militants s'en
souviennent parce que les militants
adore laurent wauquiez c'est le soir de
sa victoire à la tête de l air quand lui
il veut faire le 20 heures de tf1 xavier
bertrand qui en plus je crois il a
essayé de juin il a essayé de le joindre
pendant plusieurs jours les habitants
lui répondait pas et là il apprend chez
plus à dernière minute que bertrand va
faire en même temps que lui un autre 20
heures soluce france de
saut lui manque le parti des solutions
pour annoncer qu'il quitte le parti
d'ailleurs parce qu'il n'aime pas la
tournure qu'a prise le parti donc en
fait il lui vole la vedette ça c'est ça
s'est jamais passé et donc si j'écoute
bien ce que vous dites laurent wauquiez
a quand même un pouvoir de nuisance
bien sûr xavier auprès de ses militants
quand on discute avec des présidents de
fédérations en fait et quand on discute
un peu avec les militants c'est vrai
qu'ils disent quand même vous qui il a
tenu la maison ans at il a tenu la
maison pendant que les autres étaient
partis au pire moment au moment où on
fait le parti était déplumé et il garde
en fait une certaine affection pour
parlant vu laurent wauquiez pour autant
ils savent très bien que il ne sera
jamais il est pas présidentiable en tout
cas pas aujourd'hui qu'il ne les aurais
pas mener à la victoire mais il garde
une affection pour lui et il le respecte
il aime bien en fait et ils savent que
laurent wauquiez à sa petite préférence
pour michel barnier alors laurent
wauquiez officiellement nous soutient
personne n'a bien sûr mail mais le soft
comme dit quelqu'un a pressé la droite 1
c'est un peu un panier de crabes donc
comme dit un sénateur d'ailleurs la
gauche voilà il ya une hiérarchie des
haines en fait alors laurent wauquiez a
priori non pas pour michel barnier mais
mais
évidemment que l'on wauquiez ne va pas
du tout laissé passer vos bertrand comme
ça en fait il va tout faire pour le
surveiller on a quelques semaines devant
nous il faut 4 décembre et ça promet
d'être encore passionnant merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce débat